Speaker 1: Failed.
Former President Donald Trump spoke at the
NRA convention over the weekend, and it was
as insane as you can imagine.
But the backdrop can't be ignored.
A backdrop where we have mass shooting after
mass shooting after mass shooting, and the
NRA continues to funnel money to those elected
officials who are willing to insist we should
do nothing about guns.
The problem is something else.
It's anything but.
Guns were willing to talk about almost blood
money at this point that these people are
taking from the NRA.
And Trump shows up and cheer, leads guns and
instead says, What about trans and cannabis
as explanations for shootings and the facts?
But the backdrop of all of this is more and
more mass shootings.
If you look just the last few days, a mass
shooting yesterday in Biloxi, Mississippi,
and a whole bunch of them, more than five
on Saturday in Kentucky, California, Alabama,
mass shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting.
And Donald Trump speaks to the NRA like they're
anything short of.
Quite frankly, I think we have to call it
an evil group at this point in time.
I really am careful with the language.
What evil?
I mean, wow, What other word can we use at
this point to characterize this organization?
And Donald Trump shows up, says nothing about
we might want to restrict some people's access
to some guns and instead says we need a panel
to look at whether trans and cannabis cause
mass shootings.
Speaker 5: To convene an independent outside
panel to investigate whether transgender hormone
treatments and ideology increase the risk
of extreme depression, aggression and even
violence.
I think most of us already know the answer,
don't we?
Speaker 1: Do we really know that's one of
those funny little takes?
It's a throwaway line.
I think most of us know the answer.
You don't know the answer.
No one in that room has data to say.
Trans ideology causes mass shootings.
But Trump said we should investigate it.
But like we kind of know the answer already.
Speaker 5: Well, we have to look at whether
common psychiatric drugs, as well as genetically
engineered cannabis and other narcotics, are
causing psychotic breaks.
A lot of problems.
We're having problems that we've never seen
before, and people sort of think they understand
why.
We must also be much better at detecting warning
signs of evil, disturbed young men like the
one who murdered colleagues in Louisville.
We cannot rest until we get to the bottom
of all of the sickness that we're seeing in
our country.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, at least he's conceding
that most of these events are carried out
by young men.
I guess that's something of an acknowledgment
of reality.
But he also raises this idea of psychiatric
drugs as causing mass shootings.
This is usually these folks who talk about
this are more specific and they'll actually
say, SS are our eyes.
This is something that has been explored.
And of course the difficulty with looking
at something like that is first of all, there
are so many people that are on those medications
that it can be very difficult to find causality.
But also you have to be looking at the possibility
if you were to find some correlation, you
have to consider, well, it's the folks, the
characteristics that got them put on the drugs
are what could be responsible for their actions
rather than the drugs themselves.
That's also extraordinarily difficult to study,
but they don't care.
That's not you know, if you sit Trump down
and try to explain that to him, you're not
going to get any kind of good faith response.
Trump then goes on a rant about refrigerators
and air conditioners being shoplifted.
Speaker 5: I guess when you see these gangs
of hundreds of young, usually young people
go and attack an apartment store, department
store, and San Francisco and Los Angeles and
Chicago, and they run in by the hundreds and
they're running out carrying refrigerators
and carrying air conditioners and big stuff,
big little everything, fur coats, non fur
coat, everything that.
Speaker 1: Can non fur coats, or as we might
call them coats, caring.
And again, remember what you to really understand
the sick and evil nature of this, you have
to understand the entire context here.
Oh, people in San Francisco, they're just
shoplifting free fridges.
The context is we need the guns.
We need the guns to defend ourselves and others
and so on and so forth.
A crazy speech and even I mean, listen.
The audience at these things is pretty cuckoo.
But even this audience was sort of lukewarm
on the nonsense that was spilling out of Donald
Trump's mouth.
Another strange moment during Trump's NRA
speech.
He displayed tweets displayed at tweets which
show him ahead of other Republican presidential
candidates.
Speaker 5: In a two way poll of Florida.
Last week it was Trump 47 and two sanctus
32% to six.
And there was another poll in Florida where
Trump was at 80 and to Sanctus was at 50.
And that's the Florida poll in Texas is Trump
52%.
Speaker 1: To understand that Trump essentially
brought a PowerPoint to the NRA convention.
That's what we've got right now.
It's a glorified PowerPoint two to gun nuts.
Speaker 5: $0.20 five Hailey for, uh, you
know, the only way we can lose is if we go
prevent.
Defense.
Do you agree?
You know what?
That mantra in football, where they're holding
the team to no score and then they go prevent
the last 2 minutes and they lose the game
we will never go prevent.
But you can take it.
Speaker 1: There you go.
And Trump notably very, very familiarized
with sports.
Sports.
He's a big sports guy.
Trump also capping the completely unhinged,
deranged and delusional and dangerous, I might
add, NRA's speech claiming that there is a
marxist revolution going on.
And you may say, like in what country he means
here in the United States.
Speaker 5: Congress has to step up and stop
this Marxist revolution in its tracks.
We have a marxist revolution going on, and
I think you're starting to see it.
And we have to stop it fast.
This is what we must do to save our country.
Speaker 1: And so anyway, Mark, you know the
entire Marxist meme from the right, it's quite
laughable.
And to me the funniest part about it is if
you actually say to them, What is Marxism?
They don't have a clue, did they?
They just don't have any idea.
And anybody who knows what Marxism it only
if you had no clue what it was might you think
that there was Marxism in the United States
in any kind of position of even any power
influence whatsoever.
But of course, there are no Marxists in positions
of power in the House or Senate or federal
government.
I mean, it's it's crazy.
So top line, the most disturbing thing is
that Trump is still going and speaking to
the NRA like they're a good organization.
That's the top line.
Subsequent to that is the content and the
subject matter from Trump's speech.
And that's horrifying in and of itself.
And they've gone fully in.
On.
We're not touching guns.
Mental health?
I don't know.
Yeah, mental health.
But we won't fund it.
Let's look at mental health.
Culture, Marxism.
Transgender cannabis.
SS Alright, but the guns certainly not a factor
whatsoever.
Dangerous.
And it's not going to change anytime soon.